[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 104
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
it's good to be here.
MARK MANDEL: It's good
to be here nice and early
in the morning.
But this week, we're having
a really great conversation
with Eric Anderson,
talking all about Dataprep
and all about how you can
get your messy data clean,
especially when you
have lots of it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, he's
going to definitely touch
on the values of what
you can use Dataprep for.
And one of the
things that covers
is how it could be useful for
feature engineering, which
is going to be our question
at the end of the interview,
to talk about what is
feature engineering.
But first, what
we want to get to
is the cool things of the week.
And to start off our
cool things in the week,
last week we were talking
about performance analysis.
One thing we want to share
is that Google is actually
making Intel performance
libraries freely
available on Google
Cloud Platform.
The good thing about
this is that is actually
allowing the Intel
Xeon Scalable Skylight
Processors more performance.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Try saying that
three times quickly.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'll
try to say that a lot.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
This is something
outside of my purview,
but I guess if you're doing
Python-based scientific
programming, this seems
like the sort of thing
that you'd be interested in?
MELANIE WARRICK: I think so.
In terms of whether it can
be useful for, for sure.
But it's just the idea
of being able to make
your processors more performant
at the end of the day.
It's great to have a fast
chip, but if you can't actually
run it as fast as it should
be, then that's a problem.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
For our second cool
thing of the week,
it's actually a couple
of articles kind
of joined together, starting
with an article written
by David Mytton.
You may recognize that name
as the CEO of Server Density.
We had them on the podcast,
or him specifically
on the podcast, episode
69 talking about how
they use Google Cloud Platform.
He has a really cool
article way he refers to it
as the hidden cost of cloud.
It's a really interesting
article talking about,
basically, how, if
you're moving from,
say, something. that's
probably more of a rented VPS
or maybe you're running
your own data centers,
the differences in costs that
can occur when you're moving
to the cloud and how
you can mitigate that
and basically watch what's
happening with that.
And what's kind of cool reading
that is we literally just put
GA that the export for
Cloud Platform Billing may
[INAUDIBLE] that's
BigQuery just went GA.
So if you want to dig deeper
into how your billing is
working, especially across
products or across projects,
this is a really nice
tool for doing that.
And there's links
in the blog post to,
basically, visualize your spend
over time with Data Studio.
And if you're not
familiar with Data Studio,
it is a great way to
visualize your data that
sits inside BigQuery.
And there's actually
a drop-in demo
that basically takes
your billing data
and drops it straight into
Data Studio with some really
nice pre-built
visualizations so you
can see exactly what's
going on inside your billing
and see what money you're
spending and where.
And then you can
extend it from there,
depending on how
your business is run
and your application needs.
MELANIE WARRICK: This is
actually a really great thing
to have considering I know
that's a top-of-line priority
for most companies
when they're working
with anything around servers.
So it's good that they have
this type of tool available,
or they have this kind
of information available.
All right.
So last thing we
wanted to mention
was the fact that Kaggle is
running a competition where
you can basically use TensorFlow
for speech recognition.
They have 65,000
short sound clips
that are multiple people saying
30 different types of words,
and the idea is that
you, in essence,
are going to come up with a
model that will help identify
what is being said.
So that is running for
the next two months,
and it's got a prize of $25,000.
And we're going to
have a link on our blog
that will help take
you to where it's at.
But if you just look up
Kaggle, speech, and TensorFlow,
you'll easily find it.
MARK MANDEL: This is cool.
Kaggle does some great stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know they do.
MARK MANDEL: Big fan, big fan.
MELANIE WARRICK:
If nothing else,
even if you're not going
to do the challenge,
it's kind of great
to see the data sets
that they have available to
play around with and experiment
with.
I always tell people
when they ask me,
how do I get started
with machine learning
or where do I get data
from, I'm like go to Kaggle.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That makes a lot of sense.
Awesome.
Why don't we go have
a chat with Eric
and talk all about Dataprep?
MELANIE WARRICK: Sounds good.
MARK MANDEL: Today, I am
pleased and delighted to have
Eric Anderson, product
manager for Cloud Dataprep.
Eric, how are you doing?
ERIC ANDERSON: I'm doing great.
Thanks for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Thanks so much for joining us.
I'm super keen to hear
more about Dataprep.
It's something I
haven't personally
used a lot, so definitely
interested in what it is
and what it does.
But before we do
that, why don't you
tell us a little bit
about who you are,
what do you do at Google,
everything about you,
your five-year plan,
just all the good stuff?
ERIC ANDERSON: Right.
Yeah.
So speaking of five years,
I've been four years
at Google, all of
it on Cloud, which
is a fairly long time
for Google Cloud years.
Let's see.
I grew up in Salt
Lake City, Utah.
I still go back
probably annually,
spend a little time
whitewater rafting
there, a little rugby there.
But now, I just do computers
and hang out in the Bay Area.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Cool.
So Dataprep, this is a thing.
Can you give us the
30,000-foot view?
What is this product?
What is it meant to do?
ERIC ANDERSON: Sure.
Anyone who has worked
with data has felt
the pain of data preparation.
We talk a lot about all
the interesting things
you can do with data--
visualization,
algorithms, analysis.
And usually, we talk about it
on pretty nice and clean data.
But in the real world, there's
friction, error resistance,
and there's bad data.
And it's everywhere,
so Dataprep focuses on
that initial step used to do
any kind of data work, which
is to get your data in the
position in the structure
joined with the proper data
sets that you want so that you
can then go on and do analysis.
So it's kind of a
top-of-the-funnel,
first-of-the-workflow product.
MARK MANDEL: And when
you say data or data
set, what does that mean?
Does that mean like,
I'm at home working
on my spreadsheet for
my taxes, or does that
mean something else?
ERIC ANDERSON: It
could, but really we're
talking generally
about large data
sets, what you might
define as big data.
Presumably, these
are things that
are hard to see and find all
the errors just visually.
And so, yeah, when you
can see all the data,
then Dataprep might be the
thing to help you clean it up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm trying
to understand a little bit
more, this is kind
of like a filter
to basically clean your data.
And I understand that
concept, but what
does it look like to use it?
Data is a very generic thing.
What does it look to clean,
I don't know, phone numbers
or to clean my
credit card numbers.
It's completely different, and
there's different algorithms
involved with that.
What does it mean
to clean the data?
ERIC ANDERSON: Sure.
And I'll back up to give you
kind of a mental model and also
some mental images.
You're familiar
with spreadsheets.
Everyone is.
And you can see your data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Unfortunately, yes.
ERIC ANDERSON: Yeah.
So bad, but good also.
So good.
So you've got a grid of
your data in a spreadsheet,
but also some of us may be
familiar with like ETL tooling
or other type of
data tooling where
you would describe a flow and
processing steps, in which case
you're not looking
your data at all.
You're just looking at the
transformations or steps that
are done to change your data--
equally valid approaches.
But in the case of the
latter, the ETL tooling
or when you see a diagram
with the transformation steps,
it's hard to know exactly
what your data looks
like at any point in time.
You can see the logic
being applied to it,
but you don't know if that
logic is being applied
in the way you wanted
it, if you're getting
inputs and outputs expected.
So what we've done is kept
you in kind of the spreadsheet
paradigm.
So with Dataprep, you're
looking at a grid of your data.
But because you can't see all
of your data at the same time,
we've added additional
visual elements
to give you the sense of
the complete data set.
So we sample data
so you're looking
at a representative sample.
We apply some visual
distributions atop each column,
give you a sense for the
distribution of columns.
We also detect type and
provide some validation
on those types--
again, to give you, while you
can't see the whole column,
you can see outliers,
you can see anomalies
using these visual cues.
MARK MANDEL: So talking about
messy data or cleaning data,
what does that mean?
I just assume that all data
sets are perfect, aren't they?
ERIC ANDERSON: Sure.
I mean, it's not like
they're always erroneous,
and data sets might be
fine for one situation
and not so clean or fine
for another situation.
We're all probably familiar
with somewhat erroneous data,
like outliers or anomalies
that aren't representative.
You can imagine
transaction information
and people make returns
or improper transactions.
I mean, using point of sale,
for example, information,
if you wanted to use
that as an example.
Not everything that passes
through the [? register ?]
is something that you want to
track perhaps as an analyst.
And so, yeah, a part of that
might be cleaning and removing
those erroneous or anomalies.
But, there might be other things
done as part of preparation.
Enrichment or joining is fairly
obvious and straightforward.
It's very common to have
several different data sources
that you want to combine into
a single, fully-enriched table.
Structuring your
data so you have
a single column with a
fully-defined address
but it's hard to filter
on states when they're
embedded in a string,
and so you might
want to parse out a column
into several different columns,
for example.
So you may have
structuring steps.
Aggregations also common.
You have single
records, perhaps,
and you want to create
these into daily totals
or into hourly totals.
These are all things that
can be done in Dataprep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
all of these steps,
though, sound like something
that you could write yourself.
Is Dataprep like a
library of filters
that are useful for
common data science,
or is it more than that?
ERIC ANDERSON: Yeah, certainly.
So the common
alternatives might be SQL.
If this was stored in a
SQL-compliant database
of sorts, you could apply
SQL operations to this.
Another alternative,
common one, would be Python
or other scripting language.
There's some great
Python libraries
where you can take things
as a table or frame of data
and apply transformations to it.
In both of those
cases, again, you're
not able to see the data
itself, and you're not
able to see intermediate data.
And you're not able
to get kind of a sense
for the full data
set at one time.
There are certain popular
patterns I've used myself,
I should say.
Data scientists or
data analysts will
have a cocktail
of common queries
and/or scripts that they'll
throw at a new data set.
Describe the columns.
Show me the distributions
of each column.
So we've kind of packaged
all those common tasks
into a single view.
And in addition to just showing
you the view of your data,
we can then let you
transform it without having
to write scripts.
So if you're very
familiar in Python or SQL,
you might be productive.
But even then, we find
that even Python and SQL
experts find themselves
really productive in Dataprep.
So yeah, in addition to
just viewing your data,
you can also create
transformations, in some case
no-code transformations.
I'll just jump right into
it how that's possible.
We talked about
the distributions
and the anomaly detection we
provide you, those visual cues.
Selecting those visual
cues will select the subset
of data that applies.
And then, Dataprep
will suggest in kind
of like real time
likely transformations
to apply to that subset.
So if we showed you a bunch of
states and 10% of those states
were not actual states-- they
were territories of the United
States or something--
and you select those,
we might suggest
you remove them,
we might suggest you do
other parsing steps on them.
And then you can choose
that transformation.
So you've gone from
explore and understand
my data to remove some anomalies
without writing any code.
This has just been like reactive
gestures to the interface.
MARK MANDEL: So not only
is data prep a GUI so
that you can visualize
your information.
There's also some nice machine
learning behind the scenes
or something like that to
basically give you suggestions
on ways you could make
your data possibly
quote unquote "better?"
ERIC ANDERSON: Right.
Yeah.
You're the only judge
of better, but we've
learned from experience,
or the algorithms
learn from experience,
what is likely to be
interesting to you.
And we serve you
up several options,
and you pick from those.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So what does
it look like to use Dataprep?
How do you get the data
into it or out of it?
Because, at the end, it
really feels like you're
basically improving the data.
So I see it as a pipe
of a bigger process.
How do you connect
it to other things?
ERIC ANDERSON: The
integration points for data
are through GCS and BigQuery.
So we accept all the
standard file formats
you might expect us to on GCS.
And then we accept
BigQuery tables.
We'd like to expand
that over time,
but we've actually found
that this solves the 90% use
case for GCP users.
MARK MANDEL: Is this
like a one-time thing,
or is this something
that could be
put in a pipeline of
ongoing streaming data?
ERIC ANDERSON: I think what
we want to solve really
well initially is
necessarily the experience,
and we're delivering on that.
And that's something
that's been exciting to us.
But as soon as you
solve something one time
as an analyst or as a scientist
or whoever, most people,
they want to schedule that
thing to run all the time
or check that into production.
And so we are in the process
of adding those features.
Scheduling is soon
to arrive to allow
you to schedule that execution
to happen on some time basis.
And then, eventually, we
want to support the ability
to programmatically execute
those transformations
by other means.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I was watching a
video on Dataprep,
and it looks really cool.
And now, I get a little
bit more there of it
really looks like a
super-powered spreadsheet.
It's really cool.
But also, one of the
things that I saw
was, when you click on Run
Job, you see Cloud Dataflow.
ERIC ANDERSON: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What is the
relationship between Cloud
Dataflow and Cloud Dataprep?
ERIC ANDERSON: Great.
Yeah, great question.
We're pretty excited
about that relationship.
So for those of
you who don't know,
Dataflow is a massively-parallel
data processing service
and/or framework depending
on how you look at it.
And so it's very
powerful, and it's
based on technology
we've been developing
a Google for a long time--
MapReduce, Flume, et cetera.
So to have Dataflow at
your fingertips is awesome.
But a lot of people are ready to
use Dataflow through it's also
expressive and powerful APIs.
Currently, Java and
Python are supported.
And Dataprep, what
it allows you to do
is to express these things in
an intuitive, visual way using
Dataprep.
And then, you can know
that, even though I'm
having a great spreadsheet
experience, behind the scenes
I'm going to have also an
awesome, massively-parallel,
powerful processing experience.
So when you get Run
Job, we take the logic
that you've generated
on the sample using
either predicted transformations
or your own custom
transformations.
We package that logic
and pass it to Dataflow,
and Dataflow creates a job
that reads from your source
and writes to your destination
with all the processing
logic you defined.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
it feels like, once you
have that running, Cloud
Dataflow one of the cool things
is that you can run
it as a batch process,
or you can also
run it as something
that is continuously running.
And as soon as you
get some input,
you get the output
on the other side.
Is that possible
with Cloud Dataprep?
Like, you would basically
be fine continuously
to running Dataflow job
and then you can just
send things into the input
and get the clean version
on the other side?
ERIC ANDERSON: Yeah.
Continuously running is
something that's never really
been done in the frame of
data preparation industry,
if you want to call
it that, or landscape.
Data preparation has always
been kind of a batch thing.
What's neat about where
we're at today with Dataprep,
yes, it's batch only today.
But it is, because
we're running Dataflow,
we are submitting
Beam pipelines.
And the Beam programming
model allows both batch
and streaming.
So it would be a
natural evolution
for us to go into
streaming in the future,
and that's something I think
would be super exciting.
And we've heard some requests
for that from our users.
MARK MANDEL: So
actually, that probably
segues into a nice question.
When should a customer choose
either Dataprep or Dataflow?
It sounds like there
is crossover there.
Streaming seems like an obvious
choice because of Dataflow.
But are there other
features there
that may make someone
choose one or the other?
ERIC ANDERSON: Yeah, sure.
So I'll start with some of the
obvious, if you want call them,
limitations.
One way to think about it is
that Dataflow kind of just
supports almost anything.
It's a programming interface so
that you can almost do anything
with Dataflow, even
things that maybe you
shouldn't do with Dataflow.
Where Dataprep provides
you, it's constrained.
I should describe that we have
your transformations create
kind of script steps, and we
use a human-readable script
within Dataprep that then is
translated into the Beam SDK.
So yeah, because we're
using a DSL on Beam,
certainly we're constrained
to the limits of that DSL,
which is fairly expressive
and we actually think
is more expressive than SQL.
So you should have plenty
of room to grow there.
But yeah, currently
today, for example,
you couldn't pass
arbitrary code to Dataprep.
For that type of use, you
want to bounce out to Dataflow
and do everything there.
It is possible to, of course,
chain these into a workflow.
Because we're
reading and writing
from common sources,
GCS and BigQuery,
you could combine
Dataflow and Dataprep
into sequenced pipelines.
But more of the comparison.
So if you prefer a
visual environment,
if you prefer a human-readable
script language,
Dataprep is the
right place for you.
If you prefer the expressiveness
of a programming language
and/or maybe some of
the like data engineery
processes around a
programming language--
if you want write unit
tests, if you want
to write other kinds of tests--
Dataflow and a
programing language
is the right place for you.
MARK MANDEL: Is there any
limitation on what sort of data
formats Dataprep can handle?
Obviously, you've got BigQuery.
But if you said GCS, I could
put anything I want into GCS.
ERIC ANDERSON: Yeah.
So we take text formats.
We're going to be able
to like open most things,
but we're limited to a
handful of formats in which we
understand the structure.
So like Avro, CSV, JSON,
these are all supported.
There's a few others.
Actually, Excel files
are also supported.
We should add Sheets to that
list, but it's not there yet.
And then, I was going
to mention, for example,
XML isn't supported,
although it's
similar to JSON in a
semi-structured file format.
You'll be able to
read XML, but it
won't come in as a structured
format like the same way
that we did JSON, for example.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So what I would love
to know is, if people
are interested in Dataprep
or they seem like this
is interesting, what's
a great resource
they can go to
learn more about it?
ERIC ANDERSON: Sure.
And I should also
give you at some point
like where we're at in
our timeline and launch
and that sort of thing.
Resources, so we
have a quickstart
available and docs available.
The quickstart is like we
give you some sample data
and suggest some
transformations.
If you're familiar with the
Google Cloud Platform Codelabs,
there's actually
already a couple set up.
Some of them are designed
for using Dataprep
in the context of
machine learning, which
is something we can discuss.
And there have been a
couple blogs out there.
It's still nascent.
I'm going to go ahead
and jump into where
we're at kind of our rollout.
We announced
Dataprep, that we were
working on this, originally in
the spring at Google Cloud Next
2017.
And it was then
in what we called
a private alpha release for some
time, or private beta release.
And then, we opened
it up to a public beta
just a few weeks ago.
So now, anybody--
all you listening--
can go find it in
the Cloud Console
among all the other products.
What you should look forward
to is some additional feature
releases and a
general availability
at some point in the future.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
You mentioned Dataprep
and machine learning.
Machine learning
is the hot word,
so what's the connection there?
ERIC ANDERSON: Just what add
as many buzzwords as possible.
Often, we think about
data preparation
in the context of business
intelligence or kind
of data analyst work.
In which case, a
lot of that work,
it can be plumbing,
kind of like ETL.
It can also be a little
more higher level,
like you're trying to
arrive at some answers
and you're preparing a
data set for those answers.
But the analysis is
fairly straightforward
using straightforward
tools downstream--
data visualization,
simple aggregations.
In the case of maybe more
advanced machine and data
science, even those that are
very comfortable in Python
or whatever common machine
learning or data science
interface you prefer,
we've actually
found some people that prefer
to jump over Dataprep to do
their data preparation.
So in a machine learning
data science workflow,
you're going to take
these multiple data sets
and you're going to
combine them in some way.
And then, you're going
to do some exploration
to make sure that you
don't have too much noise
or anomalous data.
And you're also going to
do what we [INAUDIBLE]
feature engineering.
You're going to make some
judgment about what you think
are the important
features, and you're going
to put those in unique columns.
And then, you might
normalize those columns all
in preparation for then applying
you're kind of out-of-the-box
algorithms.
That upstream work around
combining the data set
can be done in Dataprep.
The feature engineering
work, in fact-- actually
separating out the important
features into unique columns
and normalizing them--
can be done in Dataprep.
If you're familiar with Kaggle,
which is this machine learning
and data science kind of
competition and forum,
community, one of the big Kaggle
users who's won a few contests
was super excited about
Dataprep and has been using it
in his Kaggle work.
So there's some
interesting work there.
Just to touch on the
workflow, these people
are probably doing
initial work in Python,
realizing that they have some
data issues or strange behavior
in their algorithms.
And they might bounce out to
Dataprep using GCS or BigQuery
as the interchange point.
And they can go back to
their Python environment,
for example, and pick up the
new data sets that are cleaned.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So it seems we're running out
of time just a little bit.
But before we do
that, we always like
to give our guests
an opportunity
to plug anything that
they think is important
or if there's something that
we haven't mentioned yet.
Is there something you
want to add to the podcast,
make sure it gets in?
ERIC ANDERSON: Yeah.
I should plug that we're
really excited, really
eager to get some
feedback on Dataprep.
We've gotten a lot of positive
responses and with that
a bunch of feature suggestions,
use cases we hadn't considered.
And then, that's
informing our roadmap.
There's a big surface
area to Dataprep.
There's a lot of
bells, whistles, knobs,
and so there's plenty of
room to explore and suggest
new things and places
where we can improve.
And we'd love to hear from you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Quick question.
So is there any
specific way that people
might want to use to
provide that feedback to you
and the team?
ERIC ANDERSON: We'd love to
hear from you on Stack Overflow.
We monitor Stack Overflow.
We also are soon to introduce
a discussion forum email
alias that you can join.
In addition to those channels,
which are available to anyone,
there's common other channels.
You can go to the
Google Cloud Meetups
and pass information
through channels there.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Eric, thank you so much for
joining us today and chatting
to us all about Dataprep.
ERIC ANDERSON: Hey,
thanks for having me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks, Eric.
Great information about
Dataprep and Dataflow.
Now, what we want to do is drive
into the question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: So we were
chatting before about the idea
of features and feature
engineering in the podcast
we did with Eric.
And so we were
chatting, and I don't
know a lot about
this space, so I
figured I'd ask
you Melanie about,
what is the
importance of features
in regards to machine
learning and why do we
need to do feature engineering?
Like, why is that a thing?
MELANIE WARRICK: So
feature engineering
has been something that spent
a priority to developing
models in machine learning,
and it's required a lot of work
in the past.
Particularly, it's used to
help drive out or define
specific attributes
of properties
about the data set that
doesn't necessarily
come across with raw data.
And it helps you
identify what's more
important to help drive the
predictive models that you're
building.
Like I said, it's
something that has
required a lot of manual
labor in the past.
It can play a large role
in terms of the preparation
or lead up to developing models.
But with deep learning
becoming such a popular thing
in the last few years, feature
engineering in particular
has become something that
we see as being automated
through deep learning.
But the reality
is, it's not fully
automated through deep learning.
It's definitely
one of those things
that is still necessary to
do some level of analysis,
so to speak.
So it's good that Dataprep
is providing that opportunity
to be able to help with the
feature engineering process.
But yeah, that's
what it's useful for.
All right.
Now, Mark, one other question
I'm going to ask for the week
is, what are you doing
for Thanksgiving?
And yes, I'm totally asking
the Australian in the States
what are you doing
for Thanksgiving.
MARK MANDEL: What am
I doing Thanksgiving?
Probably spending
all of time at home,
going to catch up with some
friends, have some food,
drink some wine,
that kind of thing.
What are you up to
for Thanksgiving?
MELANIE WARRICK: Same thing.
It's nice to have friends
that you can go visit and not
have to get on the plane.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
But speaking of
getting on a plane,
are you going anywhere,
speaking at anything
over the next couple of months?
MELANIE WARRICK:
In December, I'm
going to be going to the
NIPS conference, which
is this conference that's really
focused around machine learning
AI community.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I'll be at the Montreal
International Games Summit
in December.
But other than
that, yeah, things
are calming down for the year
nicely, which is pretty good.
MELANIE WARRICK: Are
you going to Montreal?
I'm surprised.
I didn't know you were
going to Montreal.
I had no knowledge.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I'll keep mentioning
it every week.
I just want people
to come say hello
if they happen to
listen to the podcast.
Awesome.
Well, Melanie, thank you
so much for joining me
for yet another
episode of the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
We managed to pull this one
out early in the morning
so we can get this for
Thanksgiving period.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
And we'll see you all next week.